monfort paul touvier face à la justice à
77 ans l'ancien chef de la milice de
lyon sera peut-être jugé pour complicité
de crime contre l'humanité
en allemagne le gouvernement et la
population réagisse contre les violence
de l'extrémisme en france devant le
conseil national du cds françois bayrou
annonce qu'il ne votera pas la mise en
course de laurent fabius dans l affaire
du sang contaminé
ce sont les titres du 19/20 auxquels
j'ajoute une page bande dessinée avec la
sortie du nouvel album de l'osier
portrait de l'artiste qui plonge avec
une ironie féroce dans l'univers
intellectuel culturel d'une ville de
province gérard lauzier est notre invité
ce soir nous ouvrons d'abord le journal
avec la mobilisation européenne des
agriculteurs contre le gat à 72 heures
vous le savez de la grande manifestation
qui sera organisée à strasbourg berne
josé français ont organisé aujourd'hui
une sorte de répétition générale en
paralysant les rues les entrées de la
ville de tournai en belgique
les européens découvrent la solidarité
en dénonçant leurs adversaires communs
les états unis à tournai reportage de
philippe chacun
les hommes et 15 août un essai de deux
blocs et d'europe puis c'est tout
les américains mais ils ont entre nous à
nous vendre et nous on ne fut que
américain pas d'agressivité excessive
mais de l' angoisse dans le monde
agricole belge ce matin tournée s'est
réveillé au rythme des tracteurs
plusieurs centaines d'agriculteurs du
tournaisis étaient venus manifester
contre les accords du gatt mais surtout
exprimé l'inquiétude quant à la position
non défini du gouvernement belge
si une partie de la classe politique
prend fait et cause pour le monde
agricole
rien aujourd'hui ne laisse préjuger d'un
éventuel veto du ministre de
l'agriculture le 1er décembre à
strasbourg
les agriculteurs pour sensibiliser la
population et se faire pardonner cette
inhabituelle des oeuvres avaient
organisé une distribution de pommes de
terre
que devient quant à elle passée j'ai
tous mes petits-enfants dîner pour le
citoyen enfin la gratuité
grâce aux aides aux agriculteurs et je
pense qu'on doit être tous solidaires
à les aider en font quoi il reste deux
jours au gouvernement belge pour se
prononcer clairement sur les accords du
gatt
mais déjà les agriculteurs ou à l'eau
ont rejoint unanimement les agriculteurs
français à 77 ans paul touvier va donc
retrouver la justice et l'ancien chef de
la milice de lyon reconnu comme complice
de la gestapo dans le massacre de
rillieux-la-pape en 1944 sera donc dans
quelques mois si la chambre d'accusation
de versailles fera de lui le premier
français à répondre devant un tribunal
de crimes contre l'humanité alain
chapeau désormais pour ce vieillard qui
est aujourd'hui paul touvier c'est la
tante celle de la décision qui fera
peut-être de lui le premier français à
comparaître devant une cour d'assises
pour y répondre de complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité et ce pour l'exécution
en juin 44 des sept otages juifs de
rillieux-la-pape cette brèche c'est la
cour de cassation qui l'a ouverte hier
en relevant que les actes reprochés à
l'ancien responsable de la milice de
lyon avait été commis à l'instigation de
la gestapo
voilà qui rentrent précisément dans la
définition des crimes contre l'humanité
donné lors des procès de nuremberg pour
les victimes de l'occupation c'est un
réel progrès c'est une bonne chose
en ce qui concerne ceux de rieux je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose parce
que c'est démontrer que ces trois juges
qui avaient complètement blanchi touvier
avait fait une erreur comme monumental
peuvent pas dire plus outre le cas de
paul touvier cette décision pourrait
accélérer l'instruction de deux autres
dossiers celui de rené bousquet ancien
responsable de la police de vichy et
celui de maurice papon qui fut
secrétaire général de la préfecture de
la gironde
tous deux sont actuellement inculpés de
crimes contre l'humanité pour la
déportation d'enfants juifs leur procès
ferait date tout comme celui de paul
touvier c'est me semble indispensable
il est celui de la collaboration de la
france de ceux qui ont trahi la notion
de la république française et alors que
de nombreux autres français ont
manifesté avec courage et dignité
ce qu'était la défense de l'honneur de
la france voilà donc le procès du régime
de vichy à nouveau d'actualité à moins
que la procédure ne fasse gagner un
temps précieux aux principaux accusés
politique françois bayrou fait un
distinguo entre georgina dufoix edmond
hervé laurent fabius quant à leur
responsabilité dans la sphère du sang
contaminé
le secrétaire général de l'udf a
notamment annoncé aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
voteraient pas la mise en cause de
l'ancien premier ministre françois
bayrou intervenait ce matin devant le
conseil national du cds au cours duquel
les centristes ont cherché à souligner
les marques de leur identité au sein de
l'opposition michel lemerle
joseph tual
le cd est tiraillé une fois de plus
entre unité et singularité côté unités
la préparation des législatives
les centristes creil la multiplicité des
candidatures d'opposition il fixe les
limites
une soixantaine de primaire sont
acceptables au delà attention on
entrerait dans une autre logique nous
n'adresserons pas mais nous répondrons
si nous sommes s'attaquer à ces
singularités
le programme et sa philosophie l'accent
mis sur le social ou les limites de
libre échange mais aussi le dossier du
sang le cd est estime que pour être
crédible il ne faut pas remettre en
cause de la même manière tous les
ministres concernés
un certain nombre d'entre nous estiment
que monsieur fabius ne mérite pas en
raison de ces actes d'être traduit en
haute cour et il faut lever cette
ambiguïté c'est pourquoi je propose des
actes de mises en cause séparée et que
l'on vote sur la responsabilité de
chacun
pour ma part je voterai pour la
responsabilité de madame du foie de
monsieur hervé non pas pour déclarer
qu'ils sont coupables avance mais pour
que leur cas soit examiné
et je ne voterai pas pour la mise en
cause de monsieur fabius devant la haute
cour
avis que nombre de ces déesses partager
dès le départ il avait accepté d'aller
au delà
à la demande des sénateurs rpr conduit
par charles pasqua mais trop c'est trop
déjà dans la semaine il avait accepté
par discipline
une position sur le débat du gat qui ne
les rami sait pas sur la route course et
du le cds choisira la singularité
de son côté le parti socialiste a réuni
sa convention nationale pour désigner
ses candidats et arrêté ses axes de
campagne pour les législatives avec en
toile de fond la définition d'une
stratégie à adopter face aux écologistes
daniel sportiello une frau est ce pour
le parti socialiste qui investissent et
candidat aux législatives ce dossier
toujours épineux est pratiquement bouclé
alors que l'on est à peine à quatre mois
des législatives 1 10% des
circonscriptions trouver candidat et il
ne reste qu'une petite demi douzaine de
cas litigieux
du coup les mauvaises langues murmurent
que si l'on se bat type pour les places
c'est que la bataille est perdue
d'avancé
selon les prévisions le ps perdrait en
masse plus de la moitié de ses 245 dp
candidat socialiste
quel point versez la vapeur ou est-ce
que ce soit hier sur les idiots y aller
aujourd hui tu sois s'en mordent les
doigts en mars prochain une irritation
qui s'explique par le manque
d'enthousiasmé de certains députés et
par les défections enchaîne deux
ministres en vue comme kouchner aubry
bianco ou guigou et pourtant laurent
fabius espère toujours rallier une
douzaine d'écologistes malgré l'accord
électoral intervenu entre vais jeter ray
lalonde auront leur place dans la
trentaine de circonscriptions réservées
par le ps à ses partenaires nous allons
faire une équipe avec le gouvernement et
avec d'autres le mouvement des radicaux
de gauche un certain nombre de
personnalités et j'espère que nous
pourrons faire équipe aussi avec la
sensibilité écologiste
je crois que dans cette campagne il y
aura finalement de deux forces face à
face d'un côté une alliance des forces
de progrès et de l'autre une droite
conservatrice conciliabules se crée
conversation en coulisses dans la bonne
tradition mais pas de conflit majeur à
cette convention socialiste très
conciliante
la preuve en quarts de leurs propres
ailes chevènement et mélenchon ont été
privés de s'associer à la campagne
la réponse des écologistes aux
propositions laurent fabius sera
peut-être donné demain soir dans le 19
c'est la nouvelle figure emblématique
des verts dominique voynet qui sera en
effet mes côtés pour commenter
l'actualité du jour elle sera donc le
grand et moins de 19 ans en corse des
milliers de personnes 18 mille selon les
organisateurs 13000 selon les
observateurs
toutes tendances politiques confondues
ont défilé aujourd'hui dans le calme à
bastia pour exiger pour la corse la mise
en place d'un statut fiscal dérogatoire
au droit communautaire
le chômage en france touche plus de
jeunes et plus d'hommes à l'heure où la
france fait trembler la barre des 3
millions de sans emploi les données du
chômage se modifie les femmes et les
plus de 50 ans ne sont plus à l'origine
de la poussée des inscriptions à la n2
analyse des chiffres
bernard ces gars les entreprises
licencient à tour de bras et l embauche
de moins en moins c'est essentiellement
les raisons qui expliquent la montée des
inscriptions à l'anpe au mois d'octobre
après une rentrée déjà difficile en
septembre plus de deux millions 900
mille inscriptions l'anpe cela
représente plus de 10
pour cent de la population active la
situation se détériore très nettement
pour les jeunes en un mois augmentation
des inscriptions des moins de 25 ans de
près de 3% plus les garçons que les
filles
au total de juin à septembre quatre cent
mille jeunes ont franchi les portes de
l'anpe pour la porte de sortie
les stages qui ont augmenté de 27% en un
an le traitement social du chômage donne
des résultats pour les femmes et le
nombre des chômeurs de longue durée
baisse toujours alors que le dégraissage
des faux demandeurs d'emploi se termine
le plus préoccupant est le recours des
entreprises au licenciement économique +
11 % en un an
cela ajouté au fait que l' embauche a
régressé de 25% toujours sur une année
fait craindre que le chiffre officiel
des trois millions de chômeurs cette
fois pas seulement en données brutes se
rapproche dangereusement
la proposition de l'abbé pierre fait
hier à lyon de partager le travail comme
le pain at elle des chances de
rencontrer un écho au ministère où je
les patrons en allemagne le gouvernement
et la population réagit face aux
violences de l'extrême droite des
dizaines de milliers de personnes ont
manifesté aujourd'hui dans le pays alors
que les autorités ont annoncé de
possibles privation des droits civiques
pour les chefs de parti néo-nazi
commentaires de philippe pisteurs retour
au pays mais dans un cercueil ils
étaient 3 c3 turcs eux voulaient vif la
semaine dernière en allemagne annuler
dans l'incendié de leur foyer revendiqué
auprès de la police aux cris de l hitler
à meneaux justement ce matin hommage aux
victimes et colère il était humide en
majorité de jeunes allemands à
manifester dans cette petite ville leur
slogan les nazis d'orge une marche dans
la dignité
il a fallu pourtant qu'elle soit
perturbé par des affrontements entre
turcs et militants pour qu'ils puissent
bourque dortmund ont suivi l'exemple de
melun aujourd'hui
depuis deux jours l'allemagne a décidé
de réagir face à l'extrémisme de droite
responsable de la mort de seize
étrangers depuis le début de l'année au
sein de la communauté turque très touché
comment sol une partie de la population
allemande
la colère monte contre les autorités
accusées d'avoir laissé la situation se
détériorait
dès hier le gouvernement réagisse et
interdiction d'un parti néo-nazi le
front national
d'autres pourraient suivre aujourd'hui
le ministère de l'intérieur évoque la
possibilité de priver du droit
d'expression et de certains de leurs
droits civiques
les différents leaders néo nazis le
président la république françois
mitterrand est de retour à paris après
quatre jours de visite officielle au
proche-orient en jordanie le chef de
l'état et le roi hussein ont notamment
regretté la lenteur du processus de paix
à amman christian malard durant sa
visite à amman il était important pour
françois mitterrand d'apporter son
soutien au roi hussein de jordanie
le petit souverain hachémite est partagé
entre son désir de faire la paix avec
israël celui de donner des gages à une
partie de sa population qui avait
palestinienne mais aussi celui de
ménager les pays radicaux du monde arabe
et aussi les islamistes qui sont très
puissants dans son pays qui ne veulent
pas entendre parler de paix avec l'état
hébreu
pour le président mitterrand le
règlement global aujourd'hui ne passe
que par un règlement aussi de la
question palestinienne
je ne fais pas de suggestions je
constate des évidences en fait selon ge
mon propre jugement naturellement c'est
tout réponse israélienne
d'une façon générale est habituellement
historique n'est est hostile à cette
éventualité
c'est bien c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est écrit partout où c'était par les
responsables je suis sûr d'ailleurs que
les dirigeants actuels abordé cette
question avec une position sévère sur le
fond mais qu' ils saisiront s'ils le
peuvent les chances de la paix qui l'a
permettrait de nous trouver des
interlocuteurs
mais je répète moi ce que j'en pense se
constate ça fait maintenant pas mal
d'années que c'est la responsabilité des
affaires publiques en france et je n'ai
pas encore entendu un seul responsable
si un seul me dire c'est bien je suis je
suis prêt à agir indépendamment du lp
durant son séjour donc françois
mitterrand à essayer de redynamiser un
processus de paix qui est en rade
il y a réussi partiellement dans la
mesure où les israéliens mais surtout
les arabes ont demandé à la france et au
reste de l'europe de jouer un rôle plus
important dans le processus de paix on
ne sait que tout ne sera pas facile
le processus est encore long car il faut
que les israéliens de mettre la présence
de l'ol paie à la table des négociations
n'en est pas là et puis il faut aussi
que l'amérique de monsieur clinton
prennent connaissance de tous ces
dossiers à partir du 20 janvier et
exerce peut-être des pressions sur les
israéliens afin qu elles les amènent à
discuter avec l'ol paie nouveau
président américain bill clinton devrait
annoncer la composition de son
gouvernement au cours des premiers jours
du mois de décembre le futur locataire
de la maison blanche poursuit
actuellement ses consultations
consultation parfois inattendus comme en
témoignent ses entretiens avec ronald
reagan
commentaire de joël françois dumont
quant au futur président rencontre un
ancien président des états unis
l'événement revêt à la fois un caractère
médiatique et symbolique médiatique
parce que le jeune démocrate lui qu'il
tonne a tout à apprendre du grand-clos
dicateur que furent egan pour le
remercier ronald reagan a donc tenu à
lui faire un cadeau très personnelle et
non pas une potion magique pour
s'extasiera la maison blanche m un
remède efficace paraît-il contre le
tabac et pour digérer la pilule du
congrès
quand elle est trop amère mais cette
visite de courtoisie est aussi
symbolique elle témoigne de la volonté
politique affichée de part et d'autre
pour que la transition républicains
démocrates se fasse en douceur comme le
réclament les américains nous avons
parlé de beaucoup de choses de la
transition et de la période décisive de
six mois dans la maison blanche
comment il a vécu et réussi en a
beaucoup parlé on apprend la coopération
et que bon gré le tam
je lui ai dit que je ferais là tout mon
possible cette visite d'une heure
étaient bien sûr familial car l'amérique
qu'elle soit républicaine sous reagan ou
démocrate sous clinton restera une
grande famille en france ouverture lundi
devant les assises de l'isère du procès
des assassins présumés de la petite
céline jourdan
si l'un des deux accusés didierjean t-il
reconnu les faits son compagnon de
marginalité richard roman reste l'une
des principales énigmes de cette affaire
les jurés les magistrats auront à
déterminer au cours du procès s'il a pu
ou non participé aux violences qui ont
entraîné la mort de l'enfant
l'instruction étant restés pour le moins
confus sur ce sujet reportage un gourou
marc richard roman 32 ans l'homme contre
lequel un village entier s'est dressée
l'homme qui a avoué avoir violé et tué
la petite céline avant de se rétracter
entre ces deux photos trois ans ou pas
c'est celui que l'on surnommé l'indien a
troqué son identité de marginal contre
celle plus traditionnels d'ingénieur
agronome aux cheveux courts miami heat
me berger richard roman vivait à l'écart
de la motte-du-caire dans cette ferme en
ruine avec son âne ses chèvres et les
routards de passage qui l'accueillait
fréquemment interne et deux fois pour
des crises de délire mystique
ce suspect idéal n'a pas résisté à un
interrogatoire prolonger supporter assez
mal la contrainte sociale d'une façon
générale il avait choisi de vivre comme
un marginal et donc c'est peut-être
aussi
tout d'un coup 7,7 cette irruption de
violence à tous les gars qui là qu'il a
un peu paniqué les aveux ne sont pas en
soi un mode de preuve surtout les aveux
passés à la police il y a des dizaines
de cas d'aveux dont si cela était avéré
qu'il s'agissait d'aveux faux au delà
des aveux au delà de certains
témoignages d'habitants de la mode du
caire c'est l'accusation du co inculpés
didier gentil qui pèse lourd dans le
dossier romand didier gentil a avoué
depuis le début avoir participé au viol
de céline mais l'idée était de romans
affirme-t-il
roman selon lui seuls meurtriers de la
fillette il va apparaître très frais
dans le conseil que l'un est un homme
qui est qui est beaucoup plus puissant
brimer galloway et que forcément
gentilles criminels maître à penser de
didier gentil ou victime d'une erreur
judiciaire comme le proclame son comité
de soutien
richard roman joue son avenir lundi sur
le banc des accusés les sports
maintenant et la voile avec l'hécatombe
vous le savez du vendée globe challenge
parties 14 pour faire le tour de monde
ils ne sont plus que 7 pour l'instant en
tout cas n'étaient que 7 à la sortie du
golfe de gascogne dernière victime des
avaries loïck peyron qui arrive ce soir
aux sables d'olonne pour réparer très
démoralisés et puis yves parlier qui lui
est arrivé hier et qui attend maintenant
un match tout neuf pour repartir le
point donc sur le vendée globe challenge
rémy monicelli ce mardi dernier 15
heures dans le golfe de gascogne à bord
du cac au lac d'aquitaine d'yves parlier
à cet instant vent donnait des poupons
savent déjà qu'il leur faudra faire demi
tour
mais la tempête a aussi avoir raison du
voilier d'yves parlier en quelques
secondes sur défaillance d'un des
pilotes automatiques
le voilier a viré de bord s'est couché
sur l'eau fui redresser brutalement il
doit constater les dégâts sont ma
principale est littéralement sectionné
hier après midi sur la route du retour
parliez garde le moral et regagne sous
gréement de fortune les sables d'olonne
en soirée c'est l'heure du dernier
remorquage et des retrouvailles
anticipées
l'équipe technique va maintenant
s'employer à doter cacolac d'aquitaine
d'un nouveau mât en carbone
l'opération sera coûteuse près de 700
mille francs
si tout va bien pas relié devrait
quitter les sables d'olonne mardi matin
entre temps thierry arnaud et vittorio
malines v seront déjà reparti quant à
loïc peyron attendu dans la soirée
il a décidé d'en rester là convaincu
d'avoir pris beaucoup trop de retard sur
la tête de la course où l'on retrouve
toujours ce soir alain gautier suivie de
bertrand de broc et puis la première
épreuve de la coupe du monde masculine
de ski avec une grosse déception pour le
grandissime favori alberto tomba devancé
sur la piste de sestrières en italie par
le norvégien amott de champion olympique
à mode donc du super g a devancé tombe à
2 47 centièmes et le suédois winer de
près d'une seconde
le premier français adrien duvillard
s'est classé 24e à près de trois
secondes du vainqueur son côté franck
piccard avait été disqualifié au cours
de la première nous refermons ce journal
avec la bande dessinée et la sortie du
nouvel album de l'osier baptisé portrait
de l'artiste et le moins qu'on puisse
dire gérard lauzier c'est que vous
brosser un portrait grinçant de
l'univers des maisons de la culture en
province
oui je connais pas très bien ce l'hiver
donc c'est assez imaginaire mais c'est
surtout jeu j'ai repris le personnage de
michel chevron qu'était le héros de mon
précédent album et qui maintenant se
retrouve dans une ville imaginaire de
cohérence et le grand public d'ailleurs
à bien connu puisqu'il avait donné lieu
à l'adaptation d'un film qui conte et
laure donc michel chopin c'est en
quelque sorte
et pardon de le dire comme ça j'espère
que je n'ai pas offert de peine le
prototype de l'imbécile et dernière oui
du complot on peut y aller c'est à un
artiste qu'on est il navigue dans un
univers culturel lui qui m'a touche qui
me frappe toujours un petit peu son
univers où
bizarrement toute une partie de la
production se trouve dans une zone un
peu obscur où l'extrême subtilité
rejoint la plus énorme connerie et de
temps en temps je me retrouve devant des
spectateurs dont des spectacles dans des
oeuvres théâtre ou dans une exposition
où je me pose cette question
fondamentale est-ce que c'est
extraordinairement nouveaux
révolutionnaires subtile ou est-ce que
c'est complètement con alors est ce pas
il répond dans la commune de montredon
donc être commune imaginaire bien
évidemment on retrouve des personnages
relativement criant de vérité
il y a le directeur la maison la culture
qui avait un peu échoué à paris la
grande la bourgeoise qui découvre l'art
et le théâtre j'ai acquis ce qui a une
vocation de d'actrice et donc qu'ils
jouent dans une troupe dans les prés
taux de montredon qui sont une troupe
liés aux à la maison de la culture
alors il y as depuis une dizaine
d'années vous avez consacré j'allais
dire l'essentiel de votre oeuvre vous
avez fait du théâtre avait félicité mme
hamm est donc dans le domaine de la
bande dessinée à des critiques souvent
féroce de l'univers des cadres l'univers
de la publicité maintenance ce sont je
dirais c'est un peu l'univers culturel
qui est vrai en province qui est
peut-être vrai aussi dans certains
égards à paris où j'étais un peu un
micro cause ne ce qui ressemble je crois
beaucoup enfin ce que je pense en tout
cas c'est que les roses ont beaucoup
quoi ce qui se passe à paris la promesse
maintenant il n'y a plus vraiment cette
distance entre la province et la
capitale quand on se promène un peu
d'enseignements en ce moment qu'on parle
le même langage
il ya les mêmes modes y aller même
engouement et on retrouve des
personnages qui à paris serait je ne
sais pas directeur de je ne sais quel
théâtre de la banlieue importance même
subventionnée et puis là qui sont
directeur d'une troupe qui va jouer
festival avignon alors je suis amusé un
peu d'énergie
il ya dix ans donc c'était souvenir d'un
jeune homme maintenant portrait de
l'artiste en disant que diarra fil
souple à la fin de cet album hiller il
revient à paris puisque tu sais qu'en
province et puis dans dix ans on va
connaître son ascension il va galérer un
petit peu comme on dit et puis il va
finir par dans le 3 dans le quatrième
album pas reconnaître le succès c'est là
dans 20 ans enfin et puis dans 30 ans si
je suis encore là ce sera la chute de
michel chopin
merci gérard lauzier donc portrait de
l'artiste chez dargaud dans l'instant la
météo complète de florence klein puis à
20h15 un nouvel épisode de tintin sur
l'a3 je vous retrouve à 22h15 pour le
soir notre dossier sera consacrée au
dopage dans le sport je vous souhaite un
très bon début de soirée merci
oh